And that's how you know it's literally time to go.
I'm not kidding. I'm not kidding.
I was like, I don't give a.
I don't give a fuck if I expire,
because I am expiring inside
every moment that I continue this bullshit ass bullshit.
I know that I said I was gonna do my part,
and I know that I said I was gonna, like,
have the kids and be your wife,
but, like,
it just doesn't feel like I thought it was gonna feel.
This is not what I fucking signed up for.
Like, it gets to a point where it is, like,
choking you with how much you have to choose between, like,
letting everybody else live and have their freedom.
And you just, like,
sit in this tiny prison of your own brain,
of your own making, and you're supposed to be fucking happy.
Like it,
it is I,
I will take being a single mother
with all the struggles that it comes with,
with all the lonely. Everything,
everything, like,
everything is still better then being in a miserable marriage
and feeling so empty and lonely
and used and unappreciated and undervalued.
And then you start to wonder,
do I fucking matter? Like,
maybe I am totally fucking useless, as,
like, the fucking mental jumps you have to go on
to make it right in your head
is such a fucking weight. And then to have no support,
no love. Do you know what I Mean,
like that shit when you fucking are feeling like that,
like it's time to fucking go. And I'm wishing you luck.